[Music]  i did what i had to do  to protect our world  things just got out of hand  [Music]  you break the rules  and become a hero  it doesn't seem fair  every night  i dreamed the same dream  then  the nightmare begins  i did what i had to do  [Music]  to protect our world  you cannot control everything strange  you opened the doorway between universes  and we don't know who or what will walk  through it  [Music]  wonder  what do you know about the multiverse  this had his theories  he believed it was dangerous  he was right  i'm sorry stephen  your desecration of reality  will not go unpunished  [Music]  we should tell him the truth  [Music]  things just got out of hand  [Music]  you break the rules look out  and become a hero  i do it i become the enemy  that doesn't seem fair  [Music]  [Music]  you